we got this from The Daily Beast
Georgia Governor activates 1 000
National Guard trips amid cop City
protest
I just really love how everybody is
framing this this is not a protest this
is domestic terrorists who have been
charged with domestic terrorism who shot
a cop and put him in the hospital while
trying to seize territory these are
individuals who crossed state lines with
semi-automatic weapons they did yeah
that's right I mean that's the most
shocking part and then when the cops
they fire bombed houses they fire bombed
houses houses yeah under construction
houses to make make sure the context is
clear they were building houses they
came in and they torched them a guy was
driving his truck they firebombed it he
fled they flipped his truck over these
are dangerous violent Psychopathic
terrorists gunfights gun fights with
police yeah and then when the police
went and moved in in the sky shot a cop
put him in the hospital severe injury
not critical severe they shot back
killed the guy you get leftist media
saying oh the police killed this guy you
get the activists coming out then the
activists call for the assassination of
cops now in Atlanta they are deploying
one thou or they're activating 1 000
National Guard Brian Kemp is declaring a
15-day state of emergency in Georgia
amid the civil unrest a thousand
National Guard trips are being activated
I guess
my question is this
I got a couple questions actually is
this the beginning of a new Summer of
Love is this stuff gonna going to
continually get worse do you guys think
and what should be done about it it'll
keep getting worse if we don't take the
action that Brian Kemp and then the
Atlanta police are taking right now so
as somebody from the Pacific Northwest
who had their communities absolutely
ravaged by antifa Big Time kudos to
Georgia for not putting up with this
crap and actually taking measures to
prevent it from spreading because in
2020 we did unfortunately our government
in Seattle and in Portland they just let
it go and it's it's continued to this
day and here we are in 2023 so I hope
they continue to really crack down these
guys charge them with domestic terrorism
charges
I agree
I mean I'm not I'm not I'm not a huge
fan of of uh the militarization of the
police and stuff but if you have
armed groups
that are causing that kind of chaos and
and Mayhem you're going to have a
serious problem with your Society like
Atlanta is going to have a mess until
those people get clean until they clean
up the situation and that if that means
that you have to start throwing people
in jail you have to because they're
they're ignoring the rights of the other
people in Atlanta the problem isn't oh
you know it's it's it's the problem
isn't that the Atlanta police are are
heavy-handed or whatever the problem is
that there are actual anarchists and
Communists looking to start a revolution
in Atlanta right now and that's there's
no two ways about it if you talk to them
they call themselves revolutionaries if
you talk to them they will say that you
know that they are looking to engage the
cops give them the fight they want yeah
did you ever get an Explorer go ahead I
was just gonna ask if you ever got an
explanation from like y'all's government
over why they didn't do more you know
why the inaction was you know status quo
no we got basically nothing but
gaslighting I mean they'll they'll tell
us that hey there was protesters and you
know the elected officials down in
Portland and Seattle would even go as
far as to say as like this is just
peaceful protests all the all the
cliches of you know Summer of Love that
came from Seattle I came from the Jazz I
mean up until they showed up in her
neighborhood then she called the cops
and she wanted them the heck out of
there yeah no they're still there's been
there's still there's still no
accountability yeah that was hilarious I
mean and these these guys they didn't
just trash Portland and Seattle they
came into even some of the rural
districts because they were embolden
because no one was stopping them and we
needed the government to step in and
they didn't so good on Georgia the
Communists want a revolution give them
the fight they want they're looking
they're literally looking to fight the
government government go give them the
fights well arrest them lock them up and
stop the fight well that's that's what's
gonna happen I mean you're basically
going to stomp a mud hole in their butt
the problem is
it's not it's not stopping
because they don't do anything right but
when the cops did go to try and confront
this this is what happens when you
ignore the problem yeah the police went
to confront a bunch of far leftists who
came across state lines with weapons
with semi-automatic weapons and rifles
and they shot a cop yeah the cop was in
severe condition was brought to the
hospital to get surgery they returned
fire and self-defense killing one of
these guys if they had just arrested
them but the problem is
I think there's two things
you've got Democrats who are unwilling
to confront the left wing of their own
party because it empowers them and then
you've got members of the democratic
party who agree with them yeah so you
know you guys I hope you have your
whiskey ready or whatever it is you
drink because Civil War
look I've talked about it quite a bit I
don't know exactly what shape or
whatever will happen how it's going to
happen but we're at the point now where
it's 20 23 and we're hearing that not
only have we graduated from antifa
sitting in the street taking over street
corners we now have people traveling
from across the country to seize parts
of prop big portions of land shooting at
cops
firebombing the city calling for
assassinations and being charged with
domestic terrorism we are now out of the
territory of antifa through a milkshake
and we are now in the territory of
antifa is coalescing shooting at cops
firebombing buildings again
and being charged with domestic
terrorism like the escalation is is
happening yeah will it be isolated to
Atlanta or is the summer going to be
another Summer of Love yeah I mean
unfortunately that answer like is really
up to antifa yeah I mean because we've
given them all the initiative I I hope
they keep doing what they're doing in
Georgia so maybe they'll move out of the
South and come back to the Pacific
Northwest unfortunately or New York City
but until these guys are actually
targeted and the crazy thing is that the
federal government as opposed to chasing
down every single you know grandmother
who is anywhere near the capitol on
January 6th or going after parents that
show up at school board meetings maybe
they should be going after the people
that are killing people on our streets
and burning out our entire cities like
use the FBI for that we talked about
this a few days ago when they when the
Mike Pence story happened where they
find documents in his house or whatever
and I'm like what if what if we're
dealing with a Tit for Tat what if we're
dealing with a fractured doj where of
course like you're talking about the CIA
but not every single person in the CIA
is woke and not every single person in
the CIA agrees with you in the
Constitution or is anti-woope you're
gonna have a mix I've talked to people
who worked intelligence I've got I get
emails from them I get messages and they
say like listen it's the same in here as
it is out there yeah there are some woke
people there are some not woke people
most people don't care don't want to be
involved but the woke people speak up
they get passes so I'm wondering if
the doj goes after Trump
Trump then is house rated so you'll get
some element of the FBI getting angry
and saying I'm sick of this and then
finally putting their foot down and
saying we're going after Joe Biden all
of a sudden Joe Biden's lawyers are like
yep yep yep yeah we have them we have
them here take them we're cooperated
we're cooperating and then the
anti-trump anti you know Republican
faction because oh yeah you go after
Biden we're gonna go after Pence and
then Pence is people like yup yup we
found these documents we found these
documents I'm wondering if
you know the question is why
are they going after everybody
and is it possibly a Tit for Tat where
we're seeing different factions within
the executive branch just targeting
their political enemies yeah I mean
that's
a possibility I think this could just be
one big administrative State Flex for
them just to say hey we've got dirt on
all you guys and at any point in time
we're going to find something that whole
you know show me the man I'll show you
the crime I feel like a lot of that's
going on right now because this is a
very big Power Play if you're the
administrative state within the course
of two weeks to say hey Republican and
Democrat maybe you guys had Ambitions
for 2024 we just found some paperwork
that's not straight that's that's a good
point it may be an attempt to regain
control of the system a hard whip crack
to both parties we own you yeah and by I
mean Biden's been compromised six ways
to Sunday by so many different entities
that whoever you know installed him and
propped him up and got him into office
whether whichever pathway you believe
that that took place Biden was
definitely propped up they've got so
much dirt on this guy that it was just a
matter of them deciding when you know
it's like oh is it gonna be the
classified documents barisma yeah but it
seems like they could just tell him it
seems like they'd be like Joe
have have a nice retirement and he'd be
like okay I feel like he doesn't want to
I mean he kept saying before uh like
around Christmas he was like oh well
I'll make a decision I'll make an
announcement about 2024 yeah in January
and we're all going to think about it
and then two days later he kept saying
people like oh maybe Jill doesn't want
him to run and then Judy said I was like
oh no Jill definitely wants him to run I
mean they didn't release his annual
physical like they have been super cagey
about him this whole time and he has
been insistent that he will run again so
I think Joe is not as submissive as they
would like him to be yeah uh but he's
not in good shape no he's not I mean and
that's the thing that he's he's been
compromised he went through all this
risk to be compromised now he's finally
got what he wanted I don't think he's
gonna have a fight and he's got people
around him that benefit from him being
yeah so I do think there's going to be
some you know behind the scenes fighting
there
I think that you're kind of at a point
where if you're not Vindicated now about
the whole Civil War stuff I don't see I
mean it would have to be what was that I
said I could be wrong I was just well I
mean it's already going on well that's
that's kind of what I've been saying and
the point I often bring up is like guys
I'm just reading these these news
articles about National Security
assessments like my opinion on this is
rooted in reading a bunch of news
stories that say National Security
Experts well I mean what did you have
you're like a former CIA uh uh analyst
yeah wrote a book saying we're entering
the second phase which brings us into
Civil War and I'm like okay you know
maybe I guess my chickens you got
chickens yeah we got chickens yeah we
gotta have chickens yeah yeah eggs now
are so expensive yeah and uh it's become
a crazy issue but it's funny because
look I'm not gonna tell you why eggs are
expensive like I'm just gonna say you
need to have chickens because you need
to be self-sufficient but if you really
want to know a bird flu hit chickens and
then they started culling chickens yep
so a lot of people I I had someone say
to me you're lying about inflation and
eggs you're blaming Joe Biden when it
was a bird flu that killed all these
chickens and I'm like I never said any
of that but it wasn't the bird for the
killer chickens it was orders by the
government to kill all your chickens so
apparently they were they were
instructing people to Cull their flocks
because of fear of the of the flu and
they're trying to slow it down right we
got a backyard flock they're fairly
isolated we've got to worry about
chicken diseases or anything like that
they're not going to chicken school
they're not kids
they're locked down yeah they're locked
down they're they're wrapped up you know
but but that being said considering
everything that's going on
there was a story I was reading the
other day about some 23 year old woman
from I think Seattle
she leaves the city buys a farm in the
middle of nowhere and is now prepping
and it's just like when you get a 23
year old like tick-tock influencer
what like Urban woman who's decided this
is the path for her yeah it kind of says
a lot because it used to be if you were
prepared they mocked you right now it's
the cool thing to do to go on Tick Tock
and be like yeah I'm prepping yep nobody
makes fun of Preppers anymore yeah no
well the peppers are the ones sitting
back with the whiskey in the cigar
laughing at us saying I ain't got
anything to worry about the pictures are
the ones that were like when when covid
hit off we were just like
okay
all right what now because everything I
didn't have to run to the store but
that's that's that's just overtly true I
was at a gas station in like Arizona or
something during the lockdowns and
this lady I asked her because like the
the gas station was open everything
seemed to find nobody was wearing masks
and I was like it's interesting and then
I asked her I was like have you guys
noticed anything about like with the
lockdown she's like oh we're Preppers we
don't care and I was like Ranchos we got
three months worth of toilet paper we're
not worried about toilet paper I started
laughing and then she like looks her
husband and she's like right and he's
like we got everything yeah and I'm like
okay like these people literally don't
care what's going on they're probably
laughing all the way to the toilet paper
closet yeah the Fortress of Solitude in
New Hampshire dude I was fine but can I
just mention how crazy that like
everybody knows how crazy that was but
let's just bring it up again those
videos of people
fighting over toilet paper
yeah it was wild yeah absolutely wild I
think a trip to Seattle would probably
make most people want to go prep I mean
if you're if you're prep skeptical like
just go to Seattle maybe downtown
Portland and you'll know why thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time